you
[Music]
[Applause]
I mean generally I enjoyed the performs
more than the joke I usually enjoy the
performer and his attitude you know it's
the attitude with which humorous told
which I enjoy
[Music]
that little bit of slapstick comedy by
the great Rowan Atkinson is as simple as
it gets
unsuspecting man walks into a tree it's
probably the most famous bit from the
late 1970s sketch show that atkinson
starred in called not the nine o'clock
news and what elevates it beyond a
simple joke is the same thing that makes
Atkins in one of the world's most gifted
physical comedians attitude I mean look
at this sweet little man noticing a
camera being self-conscious at first but
just at the moment he starts to feel a
little bit special
he's undercut Atkinson has the chops of
the very best physical comedians like
Charlie Chaplin Buster Keaton or Jacques
Tati
but what sets them apart I think is this
natural gift for characterization
nonverbal characterization not just the
ability to do funny things physically
but the ability to use that physicality
to broadcast an attitude the things that
make me laugh are characters you know
it's people who kind of present a sort
of truth to you I mean even though it's
mad or it's funny or it's wacky or it's
rude or it's no it's silly but there's a
sort of a truth there that you identify
with of course most people know Atkinson
as mr. bean the globally famous
character he created who's mostly
wordless antics call back to the visual
comedy of silent films most Americans
probably know him from the bean feature
films that came later but the original
sitcom which ran for only 15 episodes
across six years is where the best bean
work is that's generally because the
more cinematic the format though less
interesting mr. bean becomes Atkinson
doesn't need much more than the single
two-shot to work wonders
and unlike Chaplin Keaton Atkinson isn't
a director he's a performer through and
through this is hell
and I am the devil good evening but you
can call me Toby
if you like we try to keep things
informal here as well as infernal that's
just a little joke which is why I think
Atkinson's purest and often best work is
in his stage shows no frills just a man
and his audience these shows make the
most of Atkinson's talents the skits are
funny but the attitude in which they're
performed is the real joy try to keep
things informal here as well as infernal
that's just a little joke ancien name's
Amos
ass bandit
I'm a dick
you know a lot of prospective brides ask
me these days
father what is the church's attitude to
fellatio
and I tend to reply by telling them a
little story about the first time I was
asked that Bush these are all jokes that
require the performer to strike the
exact right tone because it's the
character that makes them work not the
punchlines
it's the way this priest cracks the
communion wafer and dips it into the
wine it's the deadpan seriousness of
this schoolmaster doing a totally absurd
roll call it's the way the devil drops
his head to the side with a bit of
self-deprecation the character is the
joke
[Music]
this is the comedy of personality rather
than the comedy of gags it's not about
doing funny things it's about doing
something quite normal in a funny way
that's actually Atkinson himself acting
in and narrating a documentary really a
long video essay on the principles of
visual comedy I'll link to it below
definitely watch the whole thing in
describing the comedy of personality
Atkinson is describing what excites him
the most but also what he's the best at
for example if you were to take the
comedy of personality to its most
extreme you'd probably get a sketch like
this one where Atkinson gives an acting
lecture portraying a bunch of different
personalities
a messenger enters bearing good news
[Applause]
[Music]
the message enters bearing bad news
messenger enters bearing bad news which
he thinks is good news
[Music]
there's really no joke at all here just
personalities and personalities within
personalities Atkinson is playing a
self-serious actor playing various
different parts the actor is proudly
displaying his talent but when something
goes wrong we get a glimpse of the
character underneath and it's even
funnier to really grasp an audience with
comedy like this takes enormous
precision and those who can do it have a
style that is completely inimitable
which is sort of ironic since being a
physical comedian requires a mastery of
imitation and a minut study of human
behavior these comedians find comedy in
the slightest things the way someone
flicks a wrist or the way someone
pronounces the first letter in a word
and he knew not whence it comes or feels
a single piano note or signifies a whole
nationality with the tiniest head
movement as well as the Russians
generally the things that make me laugh
are characters you know it's people who
kind of present a sort of truth to you I
mean even though it's mad or it's funny
or it's wacky or it's rude or it or it's
silly but there's a sort of a truth
there that you identify with and you
think I know that situation I've been
there I've seen someone like that on the
train or I am someone like that and I
and I prefer to keep it hidden and yet
here here I am being characterized
extremely well and and and that's and
that does make me look
[Music]
one of the questions you guys ask me all
the time is what kind of software I use
to make these videos well to edit I use
Final Cut Pro 10 and since 10 is so
different from the program that came
before it I depended a lot on online
videos to teach me all the new features
these days
you can pretty much teach yourself
anything this way and Skillshare is the
perfect way to do it Skillshare is an
online learning community for creators
with more than 18,000 classes and
graphic design animation web development
video game design and Final Cut Pro 10
all the classes are professional and
understandable and follow a clear
learning curve a Premium Membership
begins around $10 a month for unlimited
access to all courses but the first 200
people to sign up using the link in the
description will get your first 3 months
for just 99 cents this offer was
supposed to be only available for
January but Skillshare is extending it
out for you guys until February 15th in
those three months you could easily
learn the skills you need to start a new
hobby or business
what's the skill that you've been
putting off learning check out skill
share thanks guys I'll see you next time